(light ambient music)
(water flowing)
- Catching the fish is
definitely the biggest element.
Favorite part is always the take.
You know, when the fish takes the fly,
adrenaline just goes off.
Just casting, minding your own business,
then all of a sudden, boom!
(chuckles) That's a lot of fun.
(light ambient music)
(water flowing)
We are at Tungufljót,
which is a central river
on the south coast of Iceland.
This river is known for very big fish.
I think it's because of all the glaciers,
and this is fairly new geologically
on this part of the country.
It's fun being fishing
in this kind of weather.
Once you have your first fish
it starts to be a lot more about
the nature, the river, the company.
And being outside, getting away
from your normal life, really,
doing something else for
two or three days or a week.
That's what it's all about.
Fly fishing offers a never-ending journey,
so to speak, although it sounds a cliché,
you're never gonna master it,
no matter how hard you try,
no matter how much time
you spend doing it,
you're never, ever gonna master it.
(light ambient music)